but first my brain dump
in all culture wars there's a tipping
point a moment when those timidly bowing
to the howling mob wake up smell the
latte and grow a pair that moment
appears to have just arrived for netflix
the once mighty streaming platform has
recently seen a stop price collapse
after losing thousands of subscribers on
the content battlefield boring virtual
ceiling programming has seen its seed
key territory to belligerents like
disney apple and amazon but this weekend
netflix bosses finally realized if you
go too woke you may go broke especially
if you wave the white flag to won't
warrior staff well many of those netflix
snowflakes rose up in rage against their
firm for streaming comedy shows by dave
chappelle who makes jokes about trans
people as he does about everybody else
and then the trans community got mad
they started calling her a turf
i didn't even know what that was
but i know that
trans people make up words to win
arguments
it's kind of funny chappelle is not a
bigger he's a comedy genius he likes to
poke fun at anyone and everyone which
should frankly be the hallmark of any
good fearless comedian but the in-house
netflix wokies demanded he be cancelled
in furious protests i've got one word
for this lot
fortunately netflix have finally done
what i've been urged them to do for
weeks and told these intolerant wet
cancel culture vultures to develop a
backbone or leave in a stunning a
stinging memo to workers they said
depending on your role you may need to
work on titles you perceive to be
harmful if you'd find it hard to support
our content breadth netflix may not be
the best place for you
[Music]
finally
the message to the netflix work brigade
is now simple if you don't like the
company you don't have to work there and
the message to netflix customers is
simple too if you don't like the content
in streams and there are currently 38
000 hours to choose from you can watch
something else or cancel your sub that's
how democracy works well that's supposed
to work anyway
we need more of this rare outbreak of
what defined gumption from corporate
buses just tell them to like free speech
or lump it
it was a bratish purell attack on a
towering monument of british politics an
egg shockingly hurled towards the face
of a true westminster giant
[Applause]
incredible 21 years today since john
prescott then tony blair's deputy prime
minister punched someone who threw an
egg in his face
but that's not what i'm talking about
i'm actually talking about the
inevitable assault on margaret
thatcher's new statue
hit by eggs within two hours of being
unveiled it was originally supposed to
be outside parliament alongside other
historical titles like churchill mandela
and gandhi where frankly it belonged the
thatcher's statue was rejected by
western council several years ago amid
fears of civil disobedience and
vandalism
so we've decided to instead put it in
her hometown of grantham in lincolnshire
where she remains by far the highest
achiever in the town's history certainly
far more achieving than the protester
who turned out to be a 59 year old
publicly funded arts center deputy
director named jeremy webster
he was so proud even filmed himself
doing it boasted about his success
online imagine doing that at that age 59
and you're egging statues and going whoa
look at me
now regardless of your opinion about
margaret thatcher she was britain's
first female prime minister she won an
historic three terms she had the country
in three separate decades and was a
hugely respected figure on the world
stage yes she was divisive and
polarizing and yes by the end many
people ended up hating her but no lead
is perfect and even the parliament
square statues of churchill mandela and
gandhi have had to be
several occasions shamefully boarded up
to prevent attacks from various fanatics
so of course margaret thatcher in my
opinion should be without a statue and
of course people should be allowed to
peacefully protest about it but if
you're a 59 year old man pathetically
chucking eggs at it like a kid in the
playground then you should be forced to
clean up the mess and pay the bill and
mr webster should thank his lucky stars
the iron lady isn't still around to deal
with him personally i suspect her famous
handbag would have caused a lot more
damage than perez's punch
and the 12 points from all of europe
goes to ukraine
well obviously i quite right too i hear
you cry ukraine's win at the eurovision
song contest has been heralded as a
triumph for good over evil a stunning
show of sympathy and solidarity for the
embattled ukrainians in their hour of
need a much needed smack in the face of
vladimir putin and if the victory does
indeed bring some cheer to ukrainians at
this desperate time for the country
honestly i'm fine with that but what we
have to pretend it's a song contest
let's be honest ukraine could have sent
one of their mind-sniffing hero dogs to
bark the national anthem and they would
still have one
in fact given the norwegian entry was
two yellow dogs singing about bananas
and won almost as many public votes as
the uk
the hero dogs might actually have done
better
i'm afraid this predictable landslide
was a gigantic piece of unctuous
euro virtue signaling the tv equivalent
of people sticking a ukraine flag on
their instagram with a hug emoji and
thinking we've done our bit
or politicians clapping like seals for
president zielinski while flat out
ignoring what he's actually asking them
to give him
and it stopped britain winning when we
clearly had a far superior song on
performer which last time i checked was
supposed to be the criteria for winning
a singing contest
i've always loaded eurovision because i
hate all the absurdly partisan political
nonsense behind the voting this latest
rigged farce has merely cemented that
view and of course he won't do anything
to help defeat beauty
by contrast i applaud mcdonald's today
pronouncing is selling its entire
business in russia saying the country no
longer fits its values
mcdonald's opening in moscow 32 years
ago was a powerful symbol of the west
triumph and the cold war their departure
today is an equally powerful symbol of
russia being sent to economic siberia
good for mcdonald's punishing putin like
that will be far more effective than
pretending ukraine had the best song at
eurovision when it actually had one of
the worst
it was a thrilling relief to see the
queen looking happy and glorious at the
first major celebration of her platinum
jubilee this after so much concern of
course about her health after she missed
the state opening of parliament
the crowd's affection and relief was
obvious too a huge cheer went up as she
was driven into the show and she clearly
enjoyed herself her majesty is marking
70 years of her reign the very first
british monarch to do so and movie star
tom cruise who hosted part of a lavish
windsor celebrations last night i
thought he summed her up actually pretty
perfectly
she's met so many of your presidents in
her lifetime presidents
world leaders
people of all walks of life
i think that uh
not just america but the world knows as
i said dignity and devotion
and and
[Music]
kindness
uh someone who i think that's what we
i've always felt about her but someone
that understands her position and held
it with
through a history that's just been
extraordinary the past 70 years
perfectly put mr cruz
less positive sadly was what happened to
the queen's grandson prince william when
he attended the fa cup final on saturday
britain's biggest domestic football cup
match
[Music]
now we don't live in a dictatorship
liverpool fans have entitled taboo and
heckle william and as they are taboo the
national anthem which of course begins
with the words god save our gracious
queen
but i'm also entitled to say it was not
only disappointing it was incredibly
disrespectful to the queen if nothing
else deserves our respect in this of all
years but i fear it's a mark of the
trouble that may lie ahead for the
british monarchy which now feels like
it's entering perilous times when the
queen does pass on it will be a massive
moment for this country in the world
what comes after that sad day could be
even more significant